Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Today on the show we have Melody Bishop.
Mel is a respiratory therapist in Canada.
She has worked in transport in flight, currently works as an educator for a critical care transport
program.
She also has written an awesome book that's available for free on mechanical ventilation.
So we'll be sure to share that link with you in the description.
And then if you want to follow her, she'll mention this later, but she is at Melody Bishop
RT.
Here we go.
Now we're official.
Sounds good.
Cool.
So first thing, do you go by Melody or a short version of your name?
I love it.
Actually, that's the first time anyone's ever asked me that.
So I go by Mel, but really my family calls me that.
Professionally now most people just call me Melody.
But I also answer to RT, Hey you, that random person over there, anything like that.
Melissa, Melanie, you know, anything that's remotely an M name.
But Mel is great too.
Whatever you want to call me, it's good.
Perfect.
We'll go with Mel then.
And what do you prefer?
Ryan's pretty short, so it's not.
Yeah, Ryan doesn't have any like shortened version.
So Ryan is totally fine.
Okay.
Sounds good.
Cool.
Yeah, I guess we got in touch because you have a page on Instagram that does like education
about respiratory therapy stuff.
And I think I found out about it from Mike at the World's Okay-A-Smedic podcast, because
I think you chatted with him or he like re-shared something of yours and you have a book that
you published that's available for free on like mechanical ventilation.
Yeah.
What's the story with that?
I'm curious to know like why you put a book out for free and mainly because everyone always
asked me the same question.
Yes.
Cause I know what your book and I actually knew of your book before.
Kudos, by the way.
I love it.
It's amazing.
It's much higher level.
It gets into more of the weeds than I did in mine.
But I'll get into that in a second.
I do want to just shout out to Mike because Crunch definitely was the reason I even started
Instagram.
He like had me on his podcast just because he thought I was funny when I messaged him
on Instagram and it started a beautiful friendship.
And then he kind of pushed me annoyingly hard and I finally like ripped the bandaid and
started my Instagram page.
But prior to that, just like around COVID, I was looking around for a different mechanical
ventilation books.
And at that time I hadn't seen yours and I had seen like books for ventilation that
were written by paramedics.
And I had seen, of course there's textbooks written by physicians, but I didn't really
see anything that was written by an RT.
And I was like, you know, there really should be an RT voice in this because I think being
a non-physician designation, we have an expertise in ventilation, but also a way to maybe simplify
the concepts and bring it down from maybe a physician level or intensivist level where
they might get into more of the studies and the research and be able to explain things
in language that's easy to understand.
And also coming from a standpoint from respiratory therapy with our background and being in a
hospital and being very immersed in best practice medicine, kind of moving out of maybe some
of the practices are done.
I don't want to come off as speaking down to any profession because that's not it at
all.
But sometimes when you have a silo of paramedics teaching paramedics or nurses teaching nurses,
you don't necessarily get a complete picture of best practice when it comes to ventilation.
So and I had seen a little bit of that specifically with my hate on for SIMV that I'm always very
honest about, that I would see that a lot in books that are written by paramedics of
still teaching it as a mode that's used quite heavily.
So anyways, all that to say, I wanted to have a voice as an RT to be able to speak
to those professions that don't necessarily have mechanical ventilation in their bread
and butter of their profession and be able to explain it in a way that's easy to understand
and within one book, take someone from nothing and give them the building blocks to be able
to initiate ventilation in a situation where they don't necessarily have expertise at the
bedside like a critical care paramedic or like a physician or an RT to be safe and to
not harm someone and be able to pick settings that were appropriate for their patient and
potentially even the therapy like non-invasive versus invasive and the mode of ventilation
and they might not necessarily be at the level of a critical care provider, but be safe.
So I wanted it to be simple, easily digestible and within a very short period, get them to
at least initiating safe settings and then moving through why you would make changes
based on gases and things like that.
So that was kind of where I came up with the idea of having an RT voice to do that.
And I started just writing it while I was flying on like longer halls, just in the back
of the aircraft while I was flying.
And then I had a wonderful resource that actually I sent the book to them and they loved it
and saw the value and merited it and sent it to someone that they knew who actually
was connected with Stu College, which is a college here in Canada.
And they actually sponsored and partnered with me to get it a grant for it to be able
to release it free.
And that's kind of how it happened and why I decided to write it.
And I wanted to write it free to get it out because I wanted there to be absolutely no
barriers to any person, regardless of their background, regardless of their familiarity
with events to at least have something to start their journey and to start their journey
in a way that isn't overwhelming or scary.
Is that group, Stu, do they run the, like the book is published on this website that
like makes it pretty easy to read online, like versus mine, that's just like a PDF document.
Do they run that website as well?
Like how does, how did the hosting part of it work?
Yeah.
So the way that the grant that they helped me get the grant, Stu College, so they're
an accredited college here in Canada, but the grant actually is through the Ontario
government.
And so they have an online publication database that is an open educational resources, which
is what the grant was for.
And it was pretty much any educational resource.
It didn't have to be medical.
It could be anything else.
Could apply for a grant.
And I had to write a proposal and the rationale and the reason why.
And I honestly think COVID was worked in my favor because it was right at the time when
COVID was coming up and ventilation actually was something that the public knew about and
they heard about it on the news.
And when I pitched it to them, I said, this is, this is to increase the expertise of multiple
disciplines to be able to understand the clinical ventilation.
And I think those magic words were what really helped in the world of COVID to get them to
be able to say like, yes, we will, we will publish this and we will publish it for free.
So it's published open source and with that copyright, it can be used by anyone.
But if they use the material, they have to then publish open source as well.
So it actually locks people into a gift that keeps giving.
So they can use it.
They can use all the content, but if they want to, they have to then publish for free
as well.
Right on.
Yeah, that's cool.
That's kind of my long, long drawn out story.
But yes, for sure.
Yeah.
And I imagine that was like ideal timing because I imagine it was the same for you guys up
there.
But like here in the States, we had a lot of clinicians who don't typically use ventilators
or who were using ventilators that they're not used to working with like during that
time because we just had so many patients.
So I think like having a resource like that probably helped out a lot.
Cool.
And you mentioned this in your narrative about like how you started the book, but you also
fly.
Not anymore.
So I flew for four years.
So now I work for a critical transport company here in Canada, but actually the company that
I work for is only paramedic based.
It is like actually one of the sole companies that I'm aware of that has a paramedic paramedic
pairing.
So I work for CCPs that fly instead of like a paramedic nurse or physician nurse or physician
paramedic, like other services.
So I work for them and I'm one of their educators and I do a lot of their mechanical ventilation
airway respiratory teaching for all their CCPs and I absolutely love it.
Right on.
And do you still work in a hospital as well or just the... you do?
Yeah, I do.
So I'm actually an anesthesia assistant and I'm an RT.
So mostly when I work clinically, I now work as an RT, but I still am an anesthesia assistant
and I did work in the OR as an AA for a while.
But now mostly my clinical shifts are just RT.
Cool.
Right on.
Well, you and I have been talking a fair amount about like all things mechanical ventilation,
but I think you've seen this list as well, but I kind of put a list of questions together
to ask you about.
I don't know if we'll have time to get through all of them, but maybe we'll just dive into
those and see where it takes us.
Absolutely.
Whenever you're ready.
All right.
I'm ready.
So the first thing that I was curious in it was like, what do you think is the... maybe
not the biggest difference.
What are like some of the differences between how mechanical ventilation is done or taught
in the hospital setting versus how it's done or taught in the transport setting?
I honestly think the main difference... there's not that many differences in a good program,
but I think the main difference is as an RT or in the hospital environment, our main
ideology when it comes to ventilation is minimizing the time on the ventilator.
We're not a bridge to anything.
We're not getting a patient somewhere.
Once a patient is intubated, every single action and thing that I do is to get them
off that ventilator.
That's what I see my job is as an RT.
It's not to intubate people or to manage ventilators.
It is to get people off of them.
So when it comes to a normalized gas, I'm weaning that patient.
When the patient has a spontaneous drive to breathe, I'm considering a spontaneous mode
immediately.
There is really not a place to put paralytics in for safety or to sedate people for safety
because you don't need to do that.
If they're breathing or they have a drive to breathe, you make them comfortable in the
vent, you decrease asynchronies and you get them off the ventilator versus in transport.
Safety is paramount.
We are moving the patients around and it does shift the mindset a bit that yes, if I have
a normal gas, I'm probably not going to wean my patient.
I'm probably going to let that ride.
I'll probably leave my patient deeper and not have them lighter with their sedation
because I'm not necessarily weaning them to extubate when I know I'm about to take them
out of the aircraft in a minute and disturb them.
So I would honestly say that's probably the main difference just by nature of it being
in transport that even when I was flying, I was the same way that I didn't I wasn't necessarily
as aggressive.
I know.
Yeah, that makes sense.
What do you think?
Do you see any differences in your in your I do?
I mean, I think we'll probably get into some of these, but I think.
Yeah, I think your take on it makes a lot of sense that you're the idea of like ventilation
is like you're always working to get something off like in the hospital where I work every
time we come on shift, whether it's day shift or night shift, we're always doing an SAT
and if they pass it, they will do an SBT and we're trying to get them off the ventilator
as soon as possible.
That's like always something on our to do list.
I think there's a lot of little things that are different in like how we teach it in transport
versus like in the hospital.
Like we spend a lot of time in transport talking about like some very like nuanced specific
things and like I think at the hospital side of things, they tend to have like a the approach
like maybe those little tiny things don't matter.
Like for example, like in pre hospital setting, at least where I work really big on like want
to find everything in mechanical ventilation, whereas in the hospital side, they're like,
I don't know, just put them on settings or run a gas and then if we need to adjust it,
we can.
And I don't think there's like a right or wrong.
It's just like a different approach.
Yes, I actually like that you brought that up.
And I know one of the questions you had sent me was about like the Gestalt of bedside RT
or position of like just kind of almost feeling your way through ventilation.
You throw them on a setting, you see the volumes they're getting and then you're making
changes, but you're not necessarily calculating or looking at totally the minute ventilation
and like targeting specific numbers.
And I am a big proponent of the art and the science and those two things together.
And I do not I do definitely see within, you know, working with paramedics so closely and
working with with our ends closely that yes, like they want a number to hold on to and they
want something to really look at.
But I always I always try to remind them that like those numbers aren't necessarily
accurate.
Like then you have to dive in and dig deeper.
Like you can't see the metabolism of the patient.
You can't see the VQ matching specifically unless you're doing a metabolic study to see how
how those numbers in that minute ventilation is really going to refer to CO2 clearance.
So then like you're guessing you're still at that point guessing.
And yes, maybe you're calculating, you know, with this minute ventilation and this CO2, then
I'd have to increase my minute ventilation by this.
But then I would argue, why not improve your dead space to actual alveolar ventilation
ratio a bit better, improve your VQ mismatch.
And then once you do that, you'll be more effective.
So there is always a bit more hand waving, I think, than most people would like it to
be when it comes to ventilation.
But like, as long as you're moving in the right direction, like, I don't care if you
want a number, we can go with numbers.
And I do, when I do my training, if they want numbers to look at, then I show them
all the different calculations they can do, because I know that some people like that
when they're learning to have that safety.
Yeah, that's kind of how I've like where I've arrived at, like where I work, like they're
really big on numbers.
So like, in the workplace, like I, we calculate everything out.
And realistically, a lot of times you're like calculated after the fact, like in, like what
I'm teaching somebody, I'd say like, here's like how you would get all the numbers if
you had no idea where to start.
But in reality, like if you're like looking at a patient on the ventilator, like if everything
looks good, if you like do your normal patient assessment stuff, and like everything checks
out like just match those settings and then and then just from there.
Or if you're like starting like let's say you did the RSI, just like put them on the
defaults that your machine goes to, and then like adjust from there.
I think that's totally fine to do.
Yeah.
As long as you're not like, you know, like putting a kid on the adult defaults or whatever,
like within reason, of course.
And then like when you have a moment, you can always like do the math and like get your
numbers and then like see how it compares.
Yeah, absolutely.
Like, I always love, you know, teaching people when you're throwing someone out in a pressure
control mode, like picking a pressure control of 15, it might seem like you're just picking
a number out, but then there's actually science behind that.
It's like, okay, if you know if your pressure control is 15, then you're driving pressure
is less than 15.
So you're already safe there.
And if you're in, you know, volume ventilation, you can pick, you can do the calculation
for further predictive body weight.
And like, again, I always like, again, so I like have my soap boxes again.
Like I always say measure your patient, like get your volumes and know your safe volume
ranges and then put those in.
And then, yeah, when it comes to your respiratory rate to go with it, like I always preach demographic
norms because I'd rather have the information back from the event to know how they're exhaling
and whether there's gas trapping and things like that before I start to go beyond that.
So I might know that I might be titrating it up, but I'm not necessarily going to,
you know, calculate straight out and say, I need to have a respiratory rate of 27 in
order to get this patient to clear CO2.
Like I'm not going to start there.
I'm going to start lower.
But yeah.
How often are you or RTs in general in your system actually getting a tape measure out
and measuring patients, do you think?
Less than they should.
Yeah.
I mean, same for us too.
I measure in my pocket on the flight suit, but like almost nobody does.
I know.
I, um, like I even sometimes I'll tell people like it doesn't have to be difficult.
Like make the good choice easy.
Whenever I work at clinical shift and oh my goodness, don't tell them that my RTs I do
this because I hope they think it's just a fairy, but I actually tape the disposable
tape measures to every single ventilator that's circuited.
So when it gets wheeled into the room, it's right there.
But if you make that choice easy, then they do it.
But like, I'll be honest, there are times, oh, sorry, I didn't mean to step on you there,
but there are times that like, I don't have a measuring tape close by, but I know that
my arm span is my height.
So sometimes I'll use that as an estimate before I can go grab it and then measure.
Um, but yeah, it's not as much as they should for sure.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
I was just going to make a comment that like lowering that like barrier to doing the thing.
Mm-hmm.
Makes sense.
I say the same thing when like I say it kind of ingest, but seriously, like if I set you
up for an intubation, like if I'm your partner, like I'm going to take the style out of the
ET tube and like hand you a bougie, like that's just like, I'm going to set you up for success.
Like that way you don't have a choice.
Like you just like use a thing that gives you better success.
Um, yeah.
So I think like taping a tape measure to the machine makes sense.
Um, yeah, I would compare it maybe to like estimating weights on patients for drug doses.
Like I think we think we're pretty good at it, but we're probably not.
So like it makes sense to take a moment to measure somebody.
Yeah.
I, I really, really suggest it cause I'll be honest.
My mental math, especially in times of crisis is never as good as I think it is.
So I, I've been off some crazy times in my career where I'm like, Oh, they're probably
around six foot and they're like not anywhere near that.
And I'm like, let's see.
It's hard to tell sometimes.
For sure.
Yeah.
Especially when you have like a patient like bundled up or like a bunch of things piled
on them and equipment.
It's like kind of hard to tell.
Now, not to jump back in the conversation, but you mentioned like some differences in
in transport versus hospital.
And like, um, one thing that I have appreciated so much in, in my career is, um, changing
and moving to transport from a hospital environment and having other health, um, healthcare disciplines
teach me that like, especially when it came to airway and like the OR did a lot to teach
me, but I appreciated so much the, like how you said, like the making the best choice,
like the first choice and that like setting yourself up for every single patient that
you have the worst case scenario at your forefront and like in the OR we're good at that, but
that's something that I would say as a profession, I don't see as much as I'd like to see within
respiratory therapy when it comes to airway management, that they don't tend to set themselves
up using, you know, dash one a success for like airways and really thinking about like
the concerns for hypotension and hypoxia.
And like I even using passive oxygenation methods during their intubation and that for
EMS, that's probably horrific because that was years and years ago that that was brought
into practice.
But I, I still find, I think they have ways to go and to move and to improve in that area.
And I've appreciated so much how I've been taught in that way that I, I, I follow.
I feel like I'm a blend of professions now from the, the amazing growth that I've had
from different, like from paramedics and nurses within working with them in the past.
So it's been, it's been really amazing for me.
Yeah.
That's interesting that you mentioned that I think like in the critical care transport
in the flight world, I think like we've done a pretty decent job, like encouraging everyone
to do that sort of stuff.
I see it less in the hospital and I have a theory that that's maybe just because there's
like, it's a much more like hierarchical system in the hospital.
So like a junior provider, like doing something that seems unusual, like there's like some
resistance to that.
Whereas like in our setting, like medics and nurses and whoever's like flying on the aircraft
in whatever program you are in the States, for the most part, like it's a pretty level
playing field.
So that, that dynamic is maybe like attenuated or doesn't exist to some degree.
Um, yeah, I don't know.
I have to think about that one a little bit more.
Have you, have you noticed that as well in the hospital?
Like the things that are bread and butter to you as like, as a provider that you don't
necessarily see like from what you've seen in transport versus hospital.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
Like a lot of like the like pre-oxygenation stuff you were mentioning, like, you know,
getting a patient's head of bed up pre-oxygen with like OPA or NPA and using epic oxygenation,
like we did that stuff religiously in the field, but I don't really see that often in
the hospital.
Um, yeah, I also think in general, this is like maybe not totally related to events,
like airway management is like a huge deal to us in the pre-hospital setting.
Like we put a lot of emphasis on it.
Like we take a lot of pride in like doing that.
Um, whereas in the hospital, like all the clinicians, it's just one of like a whole
bunch of procedures they do and you always have like a team of people like to back you
up if things go wrong.
So I think there's like, it seems like the urgency to do the thing or maybe not the urgency
because it's not like, it's not a sense of urgency to get it done, but like maybe the
focus on it is less so.
Like for us, if we like take a second attempt on an airway, it's a big deal.
Like in the hospital, like I don't think anyone cares.
Like it's fine.
Be like, Hey, it was all right.
You're like, you didn't let the patient do you say that we bagged him, like try again.
But like for us, we put like a lot of emphasis on that, like first pass assess.
And I think that's fine.
Like I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
Um, I think it's just like a difference of priorities.
Like we have something to prove or as like in the hospital, they don't maybe.
I'd like to think it matters though.
Like the numbers in the studies say that the more attempts you have, the more negative
outcomes.
But yeah, I feel like we could talk about airway like all day, like it's a whole other
totally, whole other topic.
Yeah.
We'll say that one for next time.
I'm going to get in trouble with all my RTS.
Another thing that we do, or we talk a lot about in transport is clamping ET tubes.
Uh, and I was curious to get your take on that.
And then I'll spill the beans about what I see like in the hospital side of things.
Oh, I see it all in the hospital side of things.
Um, yeah.
And I feel again, like, so first off, I do have to say like when I teach clamping, I
am huge on teaching clamping on exhalation.
And the reason for that is we're maintaining PEEP.
And it's yes, like there is a lot of depending on the machine you use and the mode of ventilation
you use, there's definitely pressure control is never going to go beyond that peak pressure.
And there is often, you know, not necessarily a huge concern whether you're clamping on
inspiration, but I always say for every single ventilator, if you don't know how your ventilator
works and you don't know what mode of ventilation the patient's going to be in on the other
end, if you're, excuse me, if you're in any other mode of ventilation, like a volume mode,
you can have those pressures go too high.
So with clamping on exhalation, you are ensuring you're not applying too much pressure to the
lung to over-distend or cause potentially a double stack of a breath.
And every ventilator works differently.
And I've had ventilators before that if it's disconnects and it's on, it's going to send
the pressure out that could potentially before it connects and reads the pressure back, it
could expose the lung and we don't really know.
So that being said, there's that whole concern of, well, are we going, we're going to be
losing pressure once we clamp.
And if we don't clamp at the end of inspiration, our pressure is going to drop lower.
But then I do have to say we're not carrying, this is going to sound bad, but we're not
carrying that much because if that's the truth that we're going to like absolutely collapse
and have our patient like completely de-recruit in a second, we wouldn't be able to suction
our patients and we suction our patients and expose them to negative pressure, which then
could cause de-recruitment and it does cause desaturation, but they do recruit again.
So when people talk about needing to give them a higher pressure when clamping and clamping
at the end of inspiration to ensure that during the transition, they're not going to lose
too much pressure, I say we'll do suction your patients.
So for safety to maintain as much peep as we can, because they can de-recruit and some
ARDS patients are more sensitive or, you know, difficult to ventilate in general, hypoxia
patients are more sensitive to de-recruitment.
I suggest clamping at the end of exhalation for safety.
And the reason I do that is just because you don't necessarily know what mode of ventilation
they're going to be in on the other end.
Totally.
Yeah.
And I think this is something we've talked about before because I was always taught and
teach to clamp on inhalation for that reason where like if you clamp it, like we don't
know if your clamp's going to hold that seal, like maybe clamping is like a slow leak, but
I think it does make sense.
There is the risk there that you can stack, like you're holding peak pressure basically
and then you're giving another breath on top of that.
And we kind of talked about you could get into the nitty gritty on this.
Like if you had someone in a pressure control mode, probably isn't that big of a deal because
you're pressure limited.
Or if you had them in a volume control but you have tight parameters set on your limits,
then it's also a way to mitigate that.
But I think that's maybe something I would think about revisiting and how I teach that.
But in reality, like I think you make a good point that like we break the circuit all the
time like in the hospital, like we're breaking the circuit, like a handful of times it shifts
even on like super sick RZ patients.
So part of me thinks that like maybe this like ET tube clamping thing like doesn't matter.
It's something that we like routinely focus on in transport.
But to be honest, I've never seen anyone ever do it in the hospital.
So I was just like curious if that's a normal finding or just an anomaly for me.
My practice is any patient who is on a peep greater than 10, it is an absolute necessity
to clamp when I'm transferring them for anything in hospital.
And as best like I would still argue for any patient that is on peeps that aren't just
minimum, there isn't a harming clamping as long even for a patient who is awake and you
can talk to them and explain what you're about to do.
There's no harm in doing that clamping to maintain.
And I just suggest just decrease the time, like make sure that it's a very quick procedure.
But for patients that do de-recruit, like why not?
Why not clamp?
Why put yourself like you're really shooting yourself in the face, but you know what's
going to happen over time and that you're going to have de-recruitment specifically
with heterogeneous closing pressures of different alveoli, there are more damage than others.
And yes, we may not maintain all of the pressure.
We may have some pressure loss, but some pressure maintained is better than none.
So I would still suggest why not.
Yeah, I think that's a good point that like, as long as you like mitigate the risk of like
stacking another breath on top of like a clamp, so either by clamping an exhalation or making
sure your pressure control or like having your upper like your high pressure limit set
tight, as long as you do something to prevent damage from it, I think you can like advocate
that you should do it across the board.
So yeah, I would agree with that.
Cool, just carry on with our list here.
What are your thoughts about peep and fluid displacement?
Like pushing fluid out of the lungs?
Yeah.
This is a fun one, right?
So I was taught back in the day that peep and pressure push fluid out of the lungs.
I now at this point, the way I see it, is it more that peep can help be a bit of a stop
gap to stop the leaking while the lymphatic system clears the fluid with like the shifts
to like hydrostatic fluid, like pressures and all of those.
But at the end of the day, realistically, what we're doing is we're just expanding
the alveoli more to give more surface area.
There isn't a push of fluid across that alveolar membrane.
It just the lymphatic system is what clears it more than anything.
What are your thoughts?
Yeah, I agree with you.
I think all of us were taught at one point that like peep pushes fluid out of the alveoli.
It seems pretty clear that like the benefit in terms of oxygenation is just increased
surface area.
But I think I'm not totally convinced that like it doesn't help displace fluid to some
degree, but I think the timeline is like much more prolonged than it would matter in most
transports.
Like I think like increasing surface area in the alveoli and like making the membrane
thinner like a lot like would allow that fluid to leave more quickly over time.
But I think it's like more prolonged thing.
Like my read of it is that like this is something that happens like over like hours to days,
not something like you're not going to like push all the fluid in a CHF or as long as
out in like 20 minutes on the way to the hospital.
Yeah.
And I think as well, like if you are displacing fluid from the alveoli, where is it going
to go?
It's going to sit in the alveoli, like a pulmonary membrane.
Like it's not going away.
And then there it's still impacting the ability of oxygen to diffuse.
So realistically, what needs to happen is you need to have the lymphatic system drain
that fluid away.
So the displacement won't help you at all because all it's going to do is still be sitting
there, you know, between the the capillaries and the alveoli.
So even though it may displace it out of the lung alveoli slightly, it's not displaced
out of the entire system.
So it's still working against you.
So realistically, the body needs to clear that.
And PEEP allows, you know, potentially less leaking into the lungs and that can then over
time be cleared.
So that like that's kind of how if you really want to get into how I currently now think
of it in my mind, that's like that's kind of more of how I think about it.
But now I try to just really focus more on like we're increasing surface area to allow
more, you know, area for gas exchange to occur.
And then like, we're not necessarily pushing the fluid out.
But totally.
Yeah.
And I think in general, like that, maybe just because like the transition from like working
as like a ground medic to critical care, but I think that understanding of the concept
is definitely like, is now presented differently than when I was first learning this sounds
like maybe the same for you.
Mm hmm.
Absolutely.
And there's so many things like that that I was taught, you know, when I was newer to
the career that I've relearned over the years or like learned in a different frame or a
different form.
And it's crazy how all of that can, you know, change over the span of just a few years.
Like I've only been practicing now 17 years.
And like, I feel like what I learned back then is so vastly different to now.
Yeah.
I think that yeah, I think that's bound to happen with time.
What are your thoughts on like a hypotensive ventilator strategy?
Like doing things on the vent to like, yeah, I think everyone like agrees that like putting
somebody on positive pressure, mechanical ventilation can like decrease blood return
to the heart and cause them to become hypotensive.
But what about like intentionally using event strategy in a hypotensive patient to like
prevent it from happening to whatever degree you can?
Yeah.
And I think you were referring to a specific strategy, right?
When like with the question.
Yeah.
So basically you would use like a higher tidal volume and a lower rate.
So you like basically like decrease the amount of time when you're pushing air into lungs
above your peep and then you could potentially even like drop your peep to zero.
So like the, I guess like the most extreme version of this would be like have a tidal
volume is like high as you deem safe for your patient with a rate as low as you can to maintain
whatever you think is a minimum minute ventilation and then leave your peep at zero.
And that would be like the least impact you could have on like blood return to the heart
on preload.
Yeah.
Cause it's like less time under extreme pressure kind of idea and then like no pressure.
I looked into it.
I actually tried to look at some of the studies cause it I'll be honest, I'll be very honest.
Like I don't know close to enough about everything.
And I feel like the more I hear, I'm like, I've never heard of that before.
I'd never heard of this before.
So in my career, I've never used a strategy like this ever other than just focusing on
diminishing or decreasing peep as much as possible.
And to be fair, we never really have to because we, most clinical settings, we have access
to other things like we can give flu compressors and like you can do all the other, but like
there is like a subset of like clinicians out there who work in like resource limited
settings where like they may not have access to that stuff or maybe like on the way later.
So yeah.
Yeah.
And I think that that's a valid point cause I, I'll, whenever I hear about hypovolemia
or like different strategies for that, I always say a little like fix the problem, like try
to support the heart, support the blood, like the blood pressure and whatever means you
can that's appropriate to the type of shock that you have in order to then be able to
ventilate the patient appropriately.
So I guess like my, my concern with the idea of like, you know, hyper low rates and larger
volumes like in the one study I read, they used volumes that were well beyond what is
deemed, you know, quote unquote safe in some like in the schools of like arts net studies
that we've had from 25 years ago now of like, you know, 12 mils per kilo was the study that
I read that they used, which my concern with that would be what are the plateau pressures
that that lung is experiencing?
And then with that you are then going down to zero peep completely collapsing the alveoli
and then the shearing forces and the driving pressures that you're then experiencing to
reopen those alveoli from completely nothing.
Like when you just think about the compliance of the lung in that very low period, if you're
not adding peep, that's the time where you're going to need a lot more pressure in order
to open.
So you're you're exposing those lungs to probably more pressure than, you know, I would like
to see.
And then I wonder over for these patients that are potentially bleeding and potentially
in a traumatic arrest, they're already at an increased risk of risk of ARDS and then
you're potentially going to be exposing them to these large pressures.
It makes me nervous.
Like I would definitely I feel like I need to read more about it and to talk to people
with larger brains than mine to explain the rationale and to show me how they think that
this would still be lung protective for the patient.
I would still argue, you know, keep your peeps low, keep your pressures on the lower side,
and you'd really have to show me and convince me that like high, high pressures and high
volumes that you're going to be experiencing these large areas would actually show you
over time, you know, a significant amount of lowered pressure over time to then show
an improvement with blood pressure.
So that's kind of like my roundabout answer.
Yeah, I think that's the part that is like kind of a big unknown at the moment.
It's like, it makes intuitive sense that this would like potentially like mitigate that
effect of like dropping preload in a mechanically ventilated patient, but like at what cost?
And that's like, that's the unknown part.
Like at what point does it like not become in the patient's benefit to do that kind of
thing?
And like I said, like we could almost always like leave the vent strategy alone and use
other interventions to increase, like to address the hypotension.
So it's not really like a, does much matter for most of us like where we practice, but
it was more of like a question just like in the worst case scenario, like if you're out
straight or not island and all you have is your ventilator, which doesn't really happen
to most of us, but
Hey, you know, have a ventilator.
We'll travel.
Why not?
I had a BBM in my car for like years and years and years before I finally was like, okay,
the expiry date is really past the point that I would ever want to use this.
And also now I'm like, I don't really know.
I want to have this in my car because then I feel like I have to use it.
Yeah.
Anyways, side note, but I, I would need to read more for sure.
Like it's an interesting idea, but like, Hey, like pre hospital blood, I'm on the train
too.
Everyone should have it.
Yeah, for sure.
You have mentioned a couple of times in some of your posts about going with a title volume
of eight mils per kilo versus six.
Do you want to talk about that a bit?
Yeah.
Um, so for arts patients, that is the one population and I'm speaking about out ventilation
here, but, um, for ARDS patients or patients that are showing evidence that you're dealing
with ARDS, that's the one patient population was, I would say start at six.
But when it comes to any other patient pathology, and even when you look at ARDS net protocol,
as long as like, if you had a patient that was acidotic, that as long as you had a room
in your plateau pressures, ARDS net protocol taught you to go up to eight mils per kilo.
They would tell you to increase your total volumes, um, by one mil per kilo until you
got to eight mils per kilo.
And that is part of our net protocol.
Like that is six to eight mils per kilo within the protocol that we've been using, but everyone
kind of micro focuses on the six, which again, that is the initial settings for ARDS.
But for everybody else, we know that eight, as long as you're driving pressures and plateau
pressures are within range, it gives you a much more effective alveolar ventilation.
This is, you know, just basic physiology.
We know we have dead space.
And now with the emergence of, you know, a bunch of literature looking at intermediate
tidal volumes, there is this whole idea of this driving pressure, you know, targeted
tidal volumes that for patients that have higher compliant lungs, that they really can
get larger total volumes.
Some of the studies are going well beyond eight mils per kilo, as long as your driving
pressure is safe and, you know, sub 14, 15, 14, and that range there.
So again, I teach if you have room with your driving pressure and plateau pressure, consider,
and you need to normalize gases, consider going up to eight mils per kilo.
And the new body of research, looking at mechanical power and like all of these things are starting
to like bring all these other ideas into the picture where we know that tidal volumes,
keeping them low is not the only piece of the puzzle anymore.
And if you just think about it intuitively, like if we are banging the crap of our lungs
open and closed every single time we do that, that's going to cause trauma.
We know that.
So it's not just the amount of volumes, not just the amount of pressure.
It could also be the rate and it could also be just the amount of power that we're pushing
into the lungs from the vent.
So there is more to the picture and I'm not teaching beyond eight at all.
And please don't misunderstand me.
And if your patient has ARDS, I still abide by the idea of starting at six mils.
But if you have the ability and you need to normalize gases going with a larger volume
and getting to eight mils per kilo, if it's safe with safe pressures, it's going to be
more effective.
And then when you're, let's say like hypothetical, we started a patient on six mils per kilo
and then the driving pressure is like 10 and the plateau is obviously fine.
You're going up to eight and then you're just stopping there.
Or do you ever find a reason to go past that if the driving pressure is still low?
Great question.
As of now, I am still maxing myself at eight mils per kilo.
And we don't have enough evidence yet to go beyond that in my opinion, for me to change
my practice beyond that.
Like I think the PREVENT trial was a really great study to start to look at that and to
look at the intermediate volumes.
But we still just, we don't have enough.
I know that eight mils per kilo is safe and I know that it is even safe in ARDS patients.
And until we have more data to show that for sure, you know, in non-ARDS patients going
up to X number of mils per kilogram of predictive body weight with X driving pressure and X
mechanical power is safe as well.
I don't think that I'm ready to get there, but I think the next few years are going to
be really, really interesting.
Like just to remind people, like if you go back, because there's going to be some that
listen to this, probably it's going to, it's going to irk them.
But if you go back to the ARDS net study back from, that everything is based on, it compared
six mils per kilogram of predictive body weight to 12 mils per kilogram of predictive body
weight.
There was no in between.
And the ARDS net protocol went to six to eight.
So that is all safe.
We know that's safe.
And now we're looking at the 10 to 12 range and what that means.
And again, I'm not there yet.
I'm not doing that yet.
But who knows where the next few years will take us.
Okay.
And then a follow up question.
So let's say we start someone on title volume of six mils per kilo and we like did all of
our math.
So we come up to like a rate of 16 or 17 and then we increase our title volume up to eight
mils per kilo and we're still safe.
But now our minute volume is a little higher than our initial goal and we say our end title
start to drop.
So we're at 30.
What do you do?
Excellent question.
And I think here it depends a lot on what's the patient doing.
It depends a lot on like, no, your sedation and kind of your environment.
Are you in transport?
Are you not?
Because I think at that point you can choose if your patient is breathing and their intrinsic
respiratory rate is on the higher end, then I would probably drop my title volume.
But if my patient isn't, then, you know, at that point, both numbers are safe.
You can choose.
I probably would still suggest dropping your title volume down because why not?
It'll mean less pressure to the lungs.
Less pressure is a good thing and your rates aren't high.
But if the situation was that I was at eight mils per kilo and a higher rate, I probably
would come down on my rate if I was at a rate of like 26 or something.
And that's, I guess the art versus I like there.
I'm like, there's no right wrong answer.
Pick an answer and try it.
One other thing I wanted to mention, Ryan, is like back to the situation of like trying
to get to eight mils.
Like before I'll I'll increase my pressures or, you know, if I was in like a PRVC mode,
like increase my volumes right away for the vent to then decide or whatever, or a no volume
control mode, I would probably optimize my inspiratory time if I have a ventilator that
I have that option.
So if I'm on a mode that has a TI, if I'm in a pressure mode of any kind, I would look
to optimize time and use time to my favor and see if I can potentially get more volume
with the same amount of pressure before I even go to increase pressures.
That's kind of one great tool that you can do as well in order to optimize.
I'm sure you know, Ryan, but others might not.
Totally.
Just to like clarify that point.
So you're saying if you have somebody who were currently the way we have the vent set
up, we're getting that six mils per kilo and you're trying to get more volume per breath,
like closer to eight, you would just prolong your inspiratory time.
Yeah, and it doesn't always work.
Like you have to look at your waveforms and this is where I am a huge proponent for if
you're using a ventilator, you need to you need to dive into waveforms because that is
everything.
And I again, I feel like I'm preaching to someone that knows this.
So when it comes to looking at your inspiratory flow time curve, if you see that your inspiratory
flow is not coming down to zero before the breath cycles into exhalation, because remembering
that in any pressure mode that has an inspiratory time, your cycling mechanism is your inspiratory
time.
So if you are able to extend that inspiratory time, you will then get more volume.
But if your flow comes down to zero and you extend your your inspiratory time, you're
going to end up with an inspiratory zero flow hold, which will not give you more volume.
So you have to know your waveforms and look at your inspiratory waveform to be able to
see whether time will work in your favor or not.
So normally the classic picture is you'll see your your peak inspiratory flow, you'll
see your flow start to decay on that that decelerating slope that you see.
But then before it comes, it cuts off and just falls off click.
And if you see that, then you know that you had accessible flow, you should see that
flow time away from coming close to zero to be able to determine whether increasing time
will work in your favor or not.
Right.
Yeah, and this is something that's cool now that the price point has really come down
on the Hamilton.
And everyone seems to be using those in transport like all over the world.
It's now that we have access to those like waveforms and loops, which is pretty cool.
Yeah.
Oh, you said loops.
Oh, right.
Let loops.
Do you use the loops on the Hamilton T1?
We I mean, we look at them.
The thing is, I'm not convinced that maybe I just don't know enough about it, but I think
the loops give you information that you can also get elsewhere.
Yes.
So I'm not I'm not convinced that like you should go looking at the shapes of your loops
to like make a diagnosis, but it can confirm something, you know, or you can like see in
real time as you're doing any intervention.
But I don't know if I would like start there to go like troubleshooting what's going on
with my patient.
Yeah, a little pearl that I eventually I will get my Instagram posts to this point where
I'm going to go through this and go on a rant about it.
If you're using the Hamilton T1 and you are using your pressure volume loops, you are
you don't you don't know what you're looking at.
And I say that with all the love in the world.
And don't worry, because like I didn't have a good understanding either when I graduated
as an RT.
Remember that the Hamilton T1 is a pressure ventilator.
So the idea with your pressure volume loop, the best mode of ventilation to be able to
look at a pressure volume loop and get information out of it is when you need a ventilator where
everything is consistent except for one variable.
So a volume control mode where volume is consistent per breath and flow is controlled will give
you pressure being the variable that is changing.
So with the loops, then you can look for your opening pressures, your closing pressures,
you can look for over distention.
And yes, it's a bit hand wavy with opening pressures and closing pressures on which one
we use and all those things.
But looking for those inflection points, like really, it has it has to be a volume control
mode.
So on the Hamilton T1, we we know we don't have a true volume control mode.
We are using a pressure mode of ventilation regardless.
And since pressure is limited and volume is changing and flow is changing, you blow
past your inflection points with your pressures with it being a pressure mode too quickly
because the vent is just cycling up and then it's flattening your curve right when realistically
you'd be getting your information about over distention because we're limiting pressure.
So with that, you lose all of that great information.
So at that point, all you're left with is leaks, which you can see elsewhere, spontaneous
efforts, you can see elsewhere.
And then also you're missing everything else that you could use them for.
So you would maybe look at a loop on you'd like in a hospital setting like where I work,
like everyone is in volume control ventilation with a volume control, like a true volume
control ventilator, but not so much with pressure control, unless you're just like dirtying
out and trying to confirm what you think you already know.
Yeah.
And I tend to even I don't use even loops that much in volume control, but I would use
it more.
So when it comes to like looking for the beaking, for example, that would show you
over distention.
That's something that is very handy to look at for a volume control mode.
But again, you'll never see that with a pressure control mode of ventilation, which is what
we have on the Health and T1.
Yeah.
I've never used them more for like curiosity's sake.
Be like, oh, like what I think is going on with the patient.
I remember like what the shape is supposed to look like.
So then you like pull it up and like, oh yeah, cool.
Maybe not.
The one thing that one of my amazing coworkers, she teaches when she talks about loops is
really the only thing you're really looking at is like the upright football means a more
compliant lung.
So if the football drops to the side and horizon, then you have a less compliant lung.
But then you can look at your page three monitoring, just look at your C stat in real time.
So there isn't enough value to lose both my flow time waveform and my volume waveform.
Like keep your flow time waveform up on the screen is what I always tell people.
Yeah, I think most people are just like pulling it up to like take it.
Well, that's what I do.
I just like pull it up and take a peek at it and like flip through and like look at
all the cool things that the Hamilton gives you.
Like look at your dynamic lung, let your loops and then you like put it back on your home
screen because that's where you like need to keep an eye on things.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess.
So you mentioned looking at your like using your waveforms to adjust your inspiratory
time to decide if you can like give more or less time to maximize that tidal volume.
What do you think if you had to like pick a couple of like important things for folks
in transport to be able to like pick out of the waveforms at a glance, what's another
thing or two you would put on that list?
Fast trapping like that's like hands down.
So just making sure like it gets back to your set peep.
Yeah.
So making sure your flow time waveform it comes and even like your pressure waveforms
like that's not a good place to look at for auto peeping because the vent is going to
show you on that pressure waveform, whatever you've set.
It won't read accurately the pressures when it comes to I know and this is if you read
in that manual auto peeping is a wild thing and it's a little bit of a soapbox again,
I can get on.
Yeah.
So you have to like keep an eye on the pressure waveform to see if it comes back to your set
peep.
Yes, but it's only it may still show that it gets the peep but it's not actually all
the way there.
Yes.
Interesting.
So when I teach even like on Patreon monitoring we have auto peep is something we can read.
I don't trust that that is grain of salt grain of salt.
It's based on your settings and it's something that is calculated.
Especially when you have auto peeping in the lung, it is a dynamic process that is not
happening homogeneously through that lung.
So with that, unless you can do a true expiratory hold to then get equilibration of pressure
and actually read what is being felt with auto peeping.
If it quacks like a duck, meaning if you see on your expiratory flow waveform that you're
not getting back to zero, you have auto peep regardless of what your pressure waveform
says.
Regardless of what auto peeping you have on the other end, that expiratory flow time
waveform is the Bible that you need to follow when it comes to looking for auto peep.
And until that flow time waveform comes back to zero, treat it like you're still auto peeping
because it's going to underestimate in every other aspect what your auto peep is.
So you could have just to like reiterate this point because this is something that is new
to me.
You could have your pressure time waveform drop back to whatever baseline you have set
as peep and still have, and on your other pages in your monitoring on the Hamilton,
it could say like auto peep is zero.
But if you're seeing that the flow time, the flow waveform doesn't come all the way back
to zero, you could still have some degree of auto peep in certain regions of the lung.
Yes.
And to clarify, normally what will happen is that your auto peep will be reading like
point two, something very, very small.
But your, your expiratory flow time waveform is not coming back to zero.
And what I can guarantee you, even if you froze your waveform and you scrolled back
and you were reading your pressure and it's saying that you're reading like pretty much
5.5.1, 5.2, that is underestimating.
That is underestimating a thousand percent.
That auto peep reading that it's saying is point two is probably a lot higher than that.
And it's going to continue getting worse.
And you can see this in the manual.
If you read through the T1 manual, it says clearly multiple times that auto peep is,
is estimated and that it should not be counted on when it comes to this.
And there's also some really great studies.
I can actually send them to you after I'll look them up and send them to you that talk
about the fact that unless you're doing a true expiratory hold, auto peep is always
underestimated.
So using that flow time waveform as what grounds you as like there is auto peep and it's worse
than I think and fix it, fix it, fix it.
Right on.
And how much of a like trying to think of like how to ask this question, like how much
of a disparity is there?
Like we often teach it like a couple points of auto peep is like not a big deal as long
as they're not like seeing an increase.
Like as long as they're seeing a significant change.
So would you like always act on not seeing your flow time waveform, your flow all the
come all the way back to zero?
Would you like just note it and see if it changing it's worse or would you always address
it and get it back to zero?
I always try to fix auto peep.
That is that is my, my core in my body because it's hard to really tell until you know later
on now there are situations where the patient is doing it themselves specifically you can
think about, you know, obese patients or COPD patients where they end up doing it a little
bit.
So in those cases, I'm not too worried, but in like an asthmatic or a COPD, even then
I will still try to fix it by decreasing my rates.
If my rates are greater than, you know, 10, and I'm still seeing that flow time waveform
come back to zero, I am decreasing my rates.
So it's hard, it's hard to say like, because there isn't like one size fits all.
Usually, I will always act on a full time waveform that is not coming back to zero,
unless I have already got them down to again, like sub 10 in my respiratory rate.
And I'm still there and the patient is seeming to be stable.
And I'm still like going down every other route of trying to treat it in every way that
I possibly can.
I don't know.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Cool.
Anything else on the waveforms?
Oh my gosh, so much.
I feel like I could talk about waveforms like
I think those are like too good.
There's like two easy things to see.
Yes.
Yeah, like you can see in a glance, you don't have to like, yeah, and to like look too hard.
And then like another one is leaks.
And I have like all of these things as well.
I had videos on my Instagram that kind of go through them for those that are listening
that you can go and I walk you through auto peeping and leaks and how to recognize them
and all these different things and just the basics of the waveforms in general.
And I am at some point in the near future, starting to move into all the worlds of the
different asynchronies or dis-synchronies, however you like to say it, that exist and
how to recognize them and what to do about it and what they mean.
And trying to again, just do it in a way that makes sense and is really easy and approachable
to understand.
And it really isn't that hard once you know what to look for.
So like I would say the three major things are that auto peeping with your expiratory
waveform leaks to be able to recognize them because they can really screw up what you're
reading and what you're seeing, remembering as well the volumes you're seeing specifically
on the T1, but most ventilators, the volumes you see on your main monitoring panel is expired
volumes.
And so a lot of people don't understand that if they have a leak in place that the volumes
they're delivering are probably, they are higher than that and they could be beyond
what is safe, especially when it gets to the tiny humans and ventilating the babies.
And if they have an uncuffed tube, like this is very important when you're dealing with
the mode of ventilation that you're in and all those things.
Yeah.
And just to clarify this point, because I think that's a really good point is that when
you're measuring your exhaled volume, it's only what comes out of the tube.
You could put like 700 mils in and you only see 500 of it come out of the tube because
the rest leaks around.
So you could end up giving a lot more air than you think.
Yes.
Yeah.
And every modern ventilator should have a way for you to look through your monitoring
to see what volume went in and the vent will read it.
But just recognizing that what is on the main screen as the default one you see from every
ventilator I've ever worked with.
And there's a lot of them.
It's always expired.
And that's always something that kind of shocks people.
And like, if you're dealing with a CMV plus on the Hamilton T1 or what's the other name
for an APV CMV or something, that is a volume target mode that is targeting exhaled volumes
and going to deliver pressures to hit that exhaled volume.
So leaks will work against you if you're not able to recognize them.
And it's a very easy thing to see and to be able to then act on.
Yeah.
I think the only exception in terms of ventilators that we still see out there that don't have
a flow sensor to measure an exhaled volume would be the, what's the new name for the
ZOEMV or the old Eagle Med.
Those ones don't have a sensor to measure like exhaled flow.
But those are mostly getting phased out, but we still see them sometimes.
Well, and hey, not knocking events that don't have a proximal flow sensor at the patient,
I've used with many of them.
And like my absolute favorite ventilator I've ever used, RIP PB840, I loved you.
Did not have a flow sensor at the patient and it read the volumes back at the vent and
that vent was brilliant.
I loved it so much.
It's gone now.
I'm still crying about it, but the vents are still great, but they still are reading what's
coming back to the machine to then tell you on that main screen.
And I didn't get to my third thing, but to say really quickly is auto triggering.
That's the other thing that everyone should be able to recognize in a waveform.
Right on.
And we'll direct everyone to your videos if they're not familiar with that.
Yes, I go through all the different causes.
Cool.
How are we doing on time?
Do you still have time?
We got a hand for you.
Yeah, why not?
All right.
Yeah.
For troubleshooting, what are your thoughts on the dope mnemonic?
I love it.
I do suggest the dopes with the S's, as many S's as you can fit on the end.
I think there is a lot of issues that come with ventilation when it comes to synchronizing.
And I don't like the S being sedation.
I like the S being synchronizing.
If you have the ability to change your ventilation, even in micro amounts to make it more comfortable
to mean less sedation, that is something that I would really strongly recommend for practitioners
as the next frontier in their ventilation skills.
It might not be your first level, but once you're comfortable where you are, then starting
to learn about trying to look for those signs in the waveforms telling you your patient's
uncomfortable, it'll mean less sedation, which will then mean a better blood pressure, which
will then mean less inotropes or vasopressors.
And it feeds into a much happier transport for you.
Not just...
Yeah.
This is something that when I was putting the vent book together, a lot of how I talked
about adjusting things on the ventilator for patient comfort was more of trying things
and seeing if it works because this was before the Hamilton was readily available.
So it's something I need to revisit how to present that idea now that you have data to
look at.
Whereas sometimes you have somebody who tolerates being in volume control, this is pre-Hamilton
days just fine, and other patients, they're really uncomfortable on it, but you put them
in pressure control and it works.
Prior to waveforms or without waveforms, it's hard to...
You're just guessing and trying different things, but I think now there's maybe a better
way to present that where you're looking for specific things and making changes based on
that, such as having a strategy for how you're adjusting your inventory time.
Or yeah, that's something I need to maybe look back over on the next version, refine
a little bit.
Mm-hmm.
Especially like almost everyone now is using the T1, so we have a lot more data than we
did before.
Yeah.
And that frontier I think is such a...
It is my favorite realm of ventilation.
It's an area that I am still daily obsessed with and am reading about and feel like I
am nowhere near the pinnacle of what I can possibly learn.
And I do want to just encourage everybody that feels a bit overwhelmed that this was
not stuff that was covered very well when I went to RT school.
That was 18, 19, okay?
Yeah.
Almost 20 years ago that I started my RT school and that like vents were just starting to
have waveforms.
I was still working with ventilators in an ICU that did not have a screen that had numerics
just like you would have seen in like the LTV that like spit out across the screen and
you just scroll through.
So waveforms were the next level and some vents had them, some did not.
And then starting work and starting my clinical, yes, most vents did.
But then it wasn't something that really was fit into the program very well.
And I know a lot of RTs that are graduating, it's still something that they don't feel
was covered as well.
So it's something that a lot of RTs are still learning as well.
So don't feel like it's scared too far too outside the realm of, you know, what you could
know.
It's not, it's actually once you understand what you're looking for and once you can recognize
normal, that is where you start recognizing normal and then recognizing when something
does not look normal.
And then the rest is gravy.
You just start to look at your patient and why would your flows go up or down?
What could be happening?
And then it all falls from there.
Yeah.
Yeah, it totally makes sense.
I mean, same thing, like that's kind of how we, or at least when I was learning EKGs,
we taught them the same way.
Like you need to look at like do 12 leads on all your patients for the first year or
two so you can like identify what's normal.
Then when you see something funky, you may not know what it is, but you're like, okay,
like I got to figure this out because like something is not normal.
Yeah.
I think that's a good approach.
Just to loop back to the dope question, the reason I asked that question is because I
tend to be like a anti-dope mnemonic person.
I think I'm like anti-mnemonics in general because I think like a lot of times we have
so many to remember and then, you know, like oftentimes you can like remember the letters
but you don't actually like remember what they stand for.
I think they can like, they can like hang you up a little bit.
We also like, I have noticed in transport, we tend to like teach that the dope mnemonic
addresses like all the possible problems you could run into with ventilation, which is
definitely not true.
So yeah, like I sometimes, I'm not convinced that it's like the best framework for like
approaching problems, but I think like as long as you're aware of the limitations that
everything is like totally fine to use.
I just, yeah, I think we sometimes assume it is like a, yeah, an all descriptive like
recipe for figuring out what's going on with the ventilator and it's not necessarily the
case.
I agree with you a hundred percent.
Like, to be very transparent, the last time I actually thought about dopes in my actual
practice, I don't even, I can't remember.
I can't remember.
And it's like now when I walk to a bedside, I am using my eyes, I am using my hands and
I'm using like, I can, I can look in the waveform and know what's going on.
Like pretty much if you show me a waveform, I can tell you what's wrong.
Like the ventilator, like it's very easy to tell.
I can feel the circuit and I, and I know whether I need to suction my patient.
Like it's, I can look at my patient and how they're breathing and see the problem.
So you, you evolve past that, but sometimes in a time of cognitive load, like having the
dopes pneumonic to fall back on, especially if you're nearing your journey, I'll never
knock it.
Never, not once, because I think it will save a lot of people in a situation of like, I
don't know what to do.
Well, one of the S's is sedation.
So I can't fix this.
I don't know what's wrong.
So okay, I guess we're at the point where we're calling for paralysis and extra and
more sedation and that's okay.
Like safety is paramount and we need to be safe for our patients.
And if you don't know what's going on, disconnect and beg.
If you can't fix the problem or, you know, it's not begging and it's the patient fighting,
then there is always other things you can do in order to, to fix it.
So I don't know.
I think people do evolve past the pneumonics.
I very much agree with you.
And I think there is a point where it doesn't serve the purpose anymore, but I will never
knock someone for needing it or needing to rely on it.
Yeah, totally.
Same thing like I don't, yeah, like in our EMT or like even first responder classes,
we teach like this thing called decab, BTS, like all of the injuries you could see when
they like doing your assessment, like everyone like memorized that, but eventually you get
to a point where you like, you don't actually like need to rehearse them out loud every
time you like assess a patient.
Yes.
Yeah, absolutely.
You talked already about, you mentioned it twice, like paralysis and transport.
I think that's worth like discussing a little bit more.
I think there's generally like mixed opinions on this.
One take is that we shouldn't paralyze our patients because we want to support spontaneous
ventilation and there's like a whole bunch of advantages to that.
And then the other side is that you are also responsible for keeping that tube where it
belongs like in the correct spot and paralyzing them allows you to do that better.
I was curious to know like your thoughts in transport or what your practice is when you
were flying.
I can count on less than three fingers how many patients that I personally paralyzed
in transport.
I do have to preface this with the fact that in my flight environment that I worked, we
were like pre pre hospital flying up to remote communities that we did not do a lot of IFT
transfers like from facility to facility.
So I'm sure they're with doing inter-facility transports.
I probably would have come across when patients who are already paralyzed or already further
along in the course of their disease that they would have required paralysis.
But of the patients that I transported and a lot of them vented for long periods like
I always try to gently remind people like that some of the transports I did was upwards
of greater than seven hours.
I was flying insane distances and I didn't have to rely on that.
I flew in a lot of extreme weather conditions and there were times that I had to give a
lot of sedation or give a bolus but I tended not to fall on paralysis.
Now again, I said this as well before but I'll say it again, I will never knock a provider
for going to paralysis if there is a concern.
There is a degree of comfort that I have with being able to recognize when a patient starts
to rouse and wake up.
I can see it in the ventilator in the waveform and I also always always always carried
very, very easily accessible medications to deepen them and also predose them when
it was coming to a situation about going into minus 80 degree wind chills which I would
be exposing them to.
So all this to say, not too many times I've done it in my practice.
I don't think it's needed as much as it's done but again, if it comes down to safety
as the need, I would never ever question a decision.
Yeah, I'm kind of the same way.
We like very rarely will paralyze a patient.
But that said, I think there's like the maybe a misunderstanding that like paralyzing a
patient is like dangerous for the patient and I think sometimes that maybe is like a
little bit overblown.
I think it's totally fine in most cases like if you paralyze a patient to get them through
like a bumpy section of road or why you're like loading them.
I think it's yeah, like in years past I would have maybe had like stronger opinions on
that like, oh, like don't do that because we were like salvage whatever like spontaneous
effort they have.
But I think like with time I've kind of realized that like it's probably just fine.
And I think the caveat I would say on the other end is like going back to the beginning
when I talked about like my job as an RT is to get someone off of the ventilator as quick
as possible.
I really did fly by that mantra as well.
And like the other side of dropping a patient off at a hospital is something that a lot
of people in transport don't necessarily see.
And I can I can truly say especially when receiving a patient from a critical care flight
team, I'm not going to change their settings.
I'm going to copy their settings, whatever they're on, and I'm going to put the patient
on the same settings.
And if they're paralyzed, that means they're on a control mode.
And then by the time the nurses do the bed move and they get the patient settled and
they get all the monitors on and I'm allowed to go back into the bedside to even get a
gas or ask for a gas or have a gas drawn, most likely the actual timeline after the
patient arrives in the hospital that they are going to have a vent change done is going
to be at least four hours later, if not potentially a little longer.
There are some hospitals that don't lean on nights and don't make changes on nights.
Like I said, there's a whole range of things.
So whatever length your transport was, if they were paralyzed, even with the paralysis
waking up, if they turn the paralysis off and lighten them, it's going to be a lot longer
clinically for that patient to be on a ventilator versus if they were in a control mode and
breathing above and they got transferred over and that stimulation made them breathe a couple
more points as an RT at the bedside, I might be like, I'm going to slip into pressure for
it and see what they do.
So that might then accelerate that patient by two, three days.
Yeah, that's a significant time.
Yeah.
So is it harmful?
No.
Safety in transport is paramount and I agree with you.
It's not going to hurt your patient to paralyze them and if it makes it safer, then absolutely
do it 100%.
But if it means getting that patient off the ventilator even one day sooner, that's something
to think about.
It's food for thought.
It's a way to do it safely.
Right on.
Cool.
I just had one other thing to chat about.
What do you know about volumetric kibnography?
Not a heck of a lot.
You threw that question at the end and I was like, oh, like I'll be honest, but I like
the question.
I didn't tell you, I didn't want to talk about it because A, I think it's important to really
stress the fact that I don't know everything.
I read a little bit of the studies on it and I say it looks kind of cool.
I'm intrigued.
I'm interested.
I'd like to see more and probably get my hands on it and play with it a bit.
Have you had a chance to use it?
I only have read about it.
But I have a, my understanding of the tech, and I guess maybe we can give a little bit
of background, but the idea here is that you can measure the quantity of CO2 that is exhaled
instead of the way we do kibnography, you're just measuring like a peak concentration.
You could actually measure in milliliters or liters how much oxygen is being exhaled
with a breath or over a given amount of time.
I think the advantage, if I recall right, it's been a while since I looked into this,
is that it would allow you to accurately measure what the patient's dead space is.
And I think that provides a lot of value because dead space is kind of this elusive,
complicated idea that makes mechanical ventilation really intimidating for a lot of people.
But I think we tend to overthink the problem.
There are some things we can do in transport or even at bedside to minimize the effect.
And after that, that's kind of what we can do.
But I think being able to see it in real time, like when you pop whatever little gadget
you have in the vent circuit out and see how it changes, I think something like that would
be highly advantageous, even if you didn't have it on all the patients you're ventilating,
but if it was available in sim labs or even on non-invasive so you can demonstrate to
somebody.
I think that technology would be really good for learning and teaching, even if you didn't
have it for every patient.
I think it would really help give a number to those people that need numbers in order
to have them start to flex their targets when it comes to ventilation and really drive home
the point that sometimes a slightly larger breath and a slightly lower rate is more effective.
And if you look at the math, it makes sense that you are actually clearing CO2 at a better
rate.
So I think it would help for those people that struggle with that, that don't understand,
I don't understand, I'm increasing my respiratory rate and my CO2s aren't coming down.
Why not?
And it's like, because you're barely changing anything because the volumes you're giving
are barely clearing dead space.
So it would help.
I think the thing that also gives you that value already and not a quantifiable, not
like a number that you can actually look at and hold in your hands tangibly and say,
this is how much of my volume is getting in.
But when you correlate your gases to your end title, you're already really looking at
that relationship and seeing how much of an issue you have in VQ matching.
And that then can lead you down the path of can we optimize this in any way?
And can we improve?
And then kind of lead you down the path of is people going to work in our favor or not
using physiology as your grounding.
But I like the idea of a number for those people that need it in order to be able to
start to ventilate more effectively.
Yeah.
And I think the point you make about gases definitely makes sense.
But in transport, we oftentimes, we don't have that or we have like a single data point,
like even places that are doing gases, they will do one, maybe like a second one on arrival.
But in the hospital setting, you can get those every four hours for like, you might have
the same vented patient for like three days, you can like trend it and see how it goes.
That's something that like a lot of folks in transport just like never have had access
to.
They just can't take out of our, yeah, not really out of our, I don't know what it is.
We just don't see patients for that period of time, like you're not able to appreciate
those trends.
But something like being able to like, yeah, like eventually, I think the tech will be
there where you just like your end title detector on your monitor will like measure that cap
nography like in terms of a volume, not just like a single number.
I imagine that will exist.
I think the dead space specifically is going to be like a benefit.
I really do.
I think I do want to see it a bit more in use and like maybe studied against like those
patients where we're using blood gases.
I would love to see the value of having every service that has ventilators have a point
of care machine because I think there is value in actually targeting and chasing the
number that you should be chasing instead of a bad reflection that sometimes doesn't
even reflect the thing you should be chasing.
So like at the end of the day, pH is what we want, not PCO2 and not end title CO2.
Like pH is where we want to be.
And if you don't know what core, what compensation your patient has and what process like you
could be chasing a completely different animal.
And so I think like I would love to throw my support behind something like that.
And yes, the machines are finicky.
I stat versus epoch.
I've used them both and both have their drawbacks.
But like it's still such that the value you get back is so high.
So that's kind of my stance.
I'm not, but I'm curious to see where the volumetric and title goes.
And I think even for places that don't like carry their own ice stats, like a lot of
hospitals now like have like point of care tests like in the ICUs or in the EOS.
Yeah, like a gem.
So even if it's not like part of your like programs capabilities, you can still like
they're going to run a gem as soon as that patient gets set up.
So just like hanging around for 15 minutes and like take a look at it.
And then you can like get an idea like, yeah, it's like ventilating my patient to this like
glow and title.
And then I like look at their gas and they actually like, oh man, they're like pH like
got worse.
Like maybe I should have ventilated them to like a lower goal.
You know, you didn't like adjust your strategy a little bit just without like receiving hospitals
data point.
It's not part of like your like what you're doing clinically.
Yeah, absolutely.
It changes changes what you're targeting for sure.
Yeah.
Cool.
So one of my questions is there anything else that you wanted to mention or that you?
Honestly, like I feel like we could talk all day.
Like there's there's so many things and I think this was a this was fun.
Like we had some tech issues in the beginning, but it was it was a lot of fun.
We figured it out.
We did.
And I feel like I don't know enough about you Ryan, but I feel like I won't bore your
for the podcast with asking you questions about you.
Instead, I'll just bunny you on Instagram.
But I for everyone just that's listening.
If you want to follow me, if you're interested in hearing more and like feel free.
I love being a resource and you can find me on melody Bishop underscore RT.
But otherwise just to that because she puts up with all my questions.
I really do.
Like I just I want to be a friendly neighborhood RT that people aren't scared of asking anything
that they think is a stupid question, but I can guarantee you it isn't stupid because
I've asked way stupider ones in my in my life.
So it is I just want to be an easily accessible and friendly person that you'll never feel
stupid to reach out to.
Awesome.
Well, we appreciate that.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick before we go, just a few shout outs.
First is to pragmatic paramedics.
Another awesome podcast that we highly recommend.
Next is to the St. Fisher Church of evidence based medicine.
If you don't follow them already, definitely check them out.
These guys, both pragmatic paramedics and the St. Fisher folks have been instrumental
in getting our stuff out there into the world and we truly appreciate that.
And then we'll end things with a shout out to my good friend, Josh Pittman and his buddy,
Kevin Pons.
They put the music together for the show.
Until next time.